السنه اللي فاتت كنا تقريبا 3000 فرد
السنه دي يعني احنا عاملين حسابنا من
تلاته وسبعميه الاربعه احنا كده كده اساسا
فكره الخير في رمضان بيبقى كتير وطبعا
الفكره كلها ان انت طالما وان انت تعمل
خير فتلاقي ايه الدنيا بتمشي معكم الدنيا
بتسهل
[موسيقى]
انا مصطفى حميد من من مؤسسه الفطار
الجماعي الفكره بدات ان احنا من 11 سنه
قررنا ان احنا نفطر مع بعض انا وزمايل اول
حاجه قررنا فيها ان احنا نجيب ترابيزه
ونجيب اكل من بيوتنا ونقعد نعملها ونقعد
ناكل ايه مع بعض في الشارع طبعا الفكره دي
اتطورت سنه في الثانيه في الثالثه لغايه
لما في ناس مننا اتجوزت وعاشت بره المنطقه
فقرروا ان هم يجوا بعد بعد ما اتجوزوا من
بره بره المطريه قرروا ان هم يجوا يفطروا
معانا فالموضوع انتقل من 15 ترابيزات
لغايه العدد اللي انت حضرتك شايفه دلوقتي
داخلين في حوالي 4000 فروه الفكره كلها ان
احنا قررنا ان احنا نوحد الصنف بتاع الاكل
فقررنا ان كل البيوت في الوقت ده اللي
بتشارك معنا بالاب هتعمل محشي هتعمل رز
هتعمل فراخ هتعمل كباب حله الكلام ده كله
وحدناه عشان ما يبقاش فيه اكل مختلف عن
اكل الفكره كلها ان احنا بنعمل اكل في
البيوت وبنزله في مكان واحد للتجهيز في
اطباق فويل زي ما حضراتكم كنت شايف كده
والتصوير بارد
[موسيقى]
كل سنه حضرتك بنيجي قبل رمضان بثلاث شهور
مثلا من شهر شعبان بنعمل على الجروب
بتاعنا احنا الشباب ان احنا هنعمل الفطار
بتاعنا ان شاء الله يبقى من شهر رمضان وان
بيقدر يعمل اي حاجه بيعملها والاهالي طبعا
بتساعدنا في البيوت وامهاتنا واخواتنا
وعاملاتنا وفضلنا كلنا بنساعد بعضنا في
بيوت يعني حضرتك دلوقتي هتشوف في حيره
بنفسها كل واحد بينزل حالنا فيها قتل معين
كل ده كل ده بتحبه كل ده
الشباب والرجوله المحترمه اللي انت شايفها
قدام حضرتك
بتسع ترابيزات صغيره السنه دي اهو وانا
بتاع خمس 6000 شخص هو بيفطر ان شاء الله
معانا
[موسيقى]
كل سنه الموضوع بندرس او بنحسب ان ايه ان
السنه الجايه هيبقى في بنضاعف الكميه لان
المتوقع طبعا على السوشيال ميديا والكلام
ده كله الموضوع ايه فرق فالناس اللي بتعرف
بتيجي فالموضوع بقينا نعمل حسابنا في
الناس الضيوف كمان اللي هتيجي من بره
فبالتالي دخلنا بند ان لو في ناس زمايلنا
من بره نقدر نعزمهم يجوا يفطروا معنا نزود
العدد السنه اللي فاتت كنا تقريبا 3000
فرد السنه دي يعني احنا عاملين حسابنا من
تلاته وسبعميه لاربعه احنا كده كده اساسا
فكره الخير في رمضان بيبقى كتير وطبعا
الفكره كلها ان انت طالما وان انت تعمل
خير فتلاقي ايه الدنيا بتمشي معكم الدنيا
بتسهل
العزبه هنا والمطريه هنا كلها راجل واحد
في فعل الخير كل اللي معمول دون كل ده في
صحبه الشباب اللي طالع الاجيال الجديده هم
اللي عاملين كل ده بدون دعم من اي حد معها
عليهم اخواتنا في بيتهم وحرمنا وحريم
المنطقه كلها هم اللي بيتكفروا بالموضوع
ده وبيعملوه مع بعض وبيطلع في الصوره اللي
انتم شايفينها دي كلها يا عم الخير كله في
مصر كلها وتبقى كلها بتساعد بعضيها كده
وبتفرح وبيبقى يوم جميل كله بيفرح فيه
نتمنى ان مصر كلها تفرح كده
مجموعه من اهم المطريه عزبه حماده شباب
بيحبوا بعض فين دماء بتبقى حافه في غرفه
قاموا على فكره من تسع سنين
بدا كل واحد كل سنه لازم اصحابه اصحابه
على مدار بقى كده وحدث عظيم عن مصطفى
الجمهوريه مطريه بتادب اعظم امثال في
المحبه ونقولفه والاحتواء
فاحنا حبينا نثبت للناس لا احنا في ناس
كويسه في بذره دلوقتي سمعت في البلد كلها
يعني كل المحافظات دلوقتي خدت الفكره
وبتعملها يعني مش 15 رمضان بس اللي هي
الاساس لا ده في دلوقتي في 21 رمضان هنا
في المطريه في الاقصر هتلاقي فيه في اسوان
هتلاقي فيه في اسكندريه الفكره كلها ان في
في العاصمه هتلاقي فيه الموضوع ان هي
الفكره كلها الفكره البذره الطيبه طالما
اتحطت ربنا بيكرمه وبتلاقي ايه القدوه
الحسنه كلها ايه بتجمع طبعا انا قلت لك ان
هي الفكره كلها اللي منقوله عن المطريه دي
حاجه كانت بتضرنا احنا ورا فدلوقتي لما
لما تيجي دلوقتي الفكره كلها الموضوع يسمع
في السوشيال ميديا وفي القنوات ان احنا ان
احنا عندنا حاجه كويسه بتتعمل بكل حب وبكل
طيبه وبكل حاجه الموضوع طبعا هيفرق احنا
بنتمنى ان الموضوع بدل ما هو يبقى في
القاهره او في المطريه بس لا يبقى في
القاهره كلها يبقى كل يوم في رمضان يفطر
جماعي الفكره كلها ان الخير بذره الخيط
بتنتشر اسرع من
[تصفيق]